OKAY, GOOD MORNING. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WILL COME TO ORDER. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE WELCOME THE
PUBLIC IN PERSON, AND WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES HERE IN
THE STATE CAPITOL, WE ARE BACK.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL HAVE TIME
FOR ANOTHER HEARING, BUT WE MAY
HAVE TO SQUEEZE SOMETHING ELSE
IN. WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. AB 98 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE
REYES. SO I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMITTEE TO COME TO ROOM
112. WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AND BEGIN THE HEARING. THIS ITEM
IS BEING CONSIDERED UNDER SENATE
RULE 29.10. THIS BILL WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED, SO THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE HAS
REFERRED IT TO US TO HEAR THOSE
CHANGES. I CAN SEE BY LOOKING
AROUND ME THAT WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM. WE WILL OPERATE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY, THAT, WE WILL
HAVE THE PRESENTATION BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, AND THEN EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED TO LEAD
WITNESSES WHO WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY. SO THEY'LL COME UP
TWO MINUTES EACH AND GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY. EVERYONE ELSE OTHER
THAN THE TWO, FOUR AND THE TWO
AGAINST EVERYONE ELSE, WILL CAN
COME UP AND GIVE THEIR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL, SO I THINK WE'LL GET
STARTED. IF WE COULD HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PLEASE COME UP
AND MAKE YOUR PRESENTATION. YES.
RIGHT THERE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING. HOWEVER
YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS, FOR
HAVING US TODAY. PRESENTING THIS
BILL IN FRONT OF YOU. SENATORS,
OUR STATE AND OUR WORLD'S
ECONOMY IS INCREASINGLY RELIANT
ON THE MOVEMENT, STORAGE AND
DELIVERY OF GOODS FROM ALL OVER
THE WORLD. THE LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY HAS BOOMED OVER THE
PAST 15 YEARS AS THE RISE OF
E-COMMERCE AND OUR CONSTITUENTS
EXPECTATIONS FOR RAPID SHIPPING
HAS GROWN. FOR NEARLY A DECADE,
THE LEGISLATURE, OFTEN LED BY MÀ
JOHN ARTHUR, TODAY HAS GRAPPLED
WITH HOW TO PROTECT IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES FROM THE RISK THAT
HEAVY DUTY DIESEL TRUCKS
PRESENT. THIS FIGHT PREDATES MY
TIME HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE,
BUT AT THE REQUEST OF AT THE
REQUEST OF THE SPEAKER, I
DEDICATED MUCH OF MY TIME THIS
YEAR TO HELP HIM FIND A JUST
COMPROMISE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. MY STAFF AND I TOURED
LOGISTIC FACILITIES IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. ALSO, I'VE BEEN A CITY
PLANNER FOR NEARLY 20 YEARS. I'M
A RECOVERING CITY PLANNER NOW.
THERE IS NO DOUBT IN MY MIND,
AND I THINK YOU WILL AGREE THAT
THERE ARE PLACES WHERE HOUSES
SHOULD NOT BE BUILT. THEY ARE
SIMPLY TOO CLOSE TO PEOPLE'S
HOMES, SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY, I SAW MORE THAN A
COUPLE OF WAREHOUSES THAT, AS A
CITY PLANNER, I WOULD HAVE NEVER
RECOMMENDED FOR APPROVAL. IT IS
MY OPINION THAT SOMETHING NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, AND THE STATUS QUO
IS NOT WORKING. IT IS ALSO MY
OPINION THAT CREATING LAWS THAT
FORCE WAREHOUSES TO BE BUILT IN
THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE, OR IN
OTHER STATES IS ALSO NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE OUTCOME. THE ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS AND THE CLIMATE
IMPLICATIONS OF FORCING INDUSTRY
TO THE FAR CORNERS OF THE STATE,
OR WORST, OUT OF THE STATE
ALTOGETHER, WOULD BE A MISTAKE.
SENATORS, THIS IS A VERY
DELICATE COMPROMISE THAT, AS YOU
WILL SOON HEAR, HAS DISAPPOINTED
PARTIES ON BOTH SIDES. WELL,
THAT WAS NOT MY HOPE. WHEN WE
STARTED THIS PROCESS. I WOULD
ARGUE THAT IT'S A SIGN THAT WE
DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF FINDING
A FAIR COMPROMISE THAT, FOR THE
FIRST TIME, HAS A CHANCE TO
IMPROVE THE STATUS QUO. WITH
THAT, I WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
JOINT CO AUTHOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBER.
SENATOR I'M HERE TODAY ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JUAN CARRILLO, TO PRESENT
AB 98. THE JOURNEY TO TODAY HAS
BEEN LONG, BUT THE ISSUE HAS
ONLY BECOME MORE SEVERE WITH THE
PASSING YEARS. THE PROLIFERATION
OF WAREHOUSES IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE HAS BEEN TOUTED AS A
GREAT ECONOMIC GAIN FOR HAS
GREAT ECONOMIC GAIN FOR THE
INLAND EMPIRE, WITH THE JOBS FOR
LOCAL RESIDENTS. THE HISTORY OF
GOODS MOVEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE INCOMPLETE UNLESS WE
TALK ABOUT THE ROLE OF SAN
BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES. WE WERE AN AREA WITH
LOTS OF OPEN LAND THAT HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE SUPPLY CHAIN AND SUPPORT
INDUSTRY. THE JOURNEY HERE HAS
BEEN LONG AND TRYING, AND I'VE
ALWAYS PUT THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITY ABOVE ALL ELSE IN ALL
OF OUR CONVERSATIONS. TODAY, WE
PROPOSE AN IMPORTANT STEP. WE
CONFIRM THAT WE WANT TO MINIMIZE
ADVERSE IMPACTS ON RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES AND ENHANCE
TRANSPORTATION EFFICIENCY. AND
WE CONFIRM THAT THE IMPACT ON
PUBLIC HEALTH IS A MATTER OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN. THIS IS WHY
WE INTRODUCED AB 98. AND THIS IS
WHY THE SPEAKER PUT TOGETHER
THIS WORKING GROUP AND HAD MY
COLLEAGUE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO, AS CHAIR OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, AS CHAIR OF THAT
COMMITTEE. MANY MEETINGS AND
MANY MONTHS HAVE PASSED SINCE
THEN. AB 98 NOW PROPOSES COMMON
SENSE POLICIES, RELATED POLICIES
RELATING TO THE SITING AND
PLANNING OF LOGISTICS
DEVELOPMENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REPRESENTING THE INLAND EMPIRE,
MY COMMUNITY FEELS THIS ACUTELY.
THE INLAND EMPIRE IS HOME TO
OVER 4000 WAREHOUSES TAKING UP
OVER 1,000,000,000FT², RESULTING
IN OVER 600,000 TRUCK TRIPS PER
DAY. THIS HAS RESULTED IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN MY
COMMUNITY, WHERE AMONG OTHER
THINGS, WE HAVE THE WORST OZONE
POLLUTION IN THE COUNTRY,
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION, AB 98 HAS BEEN
THOUGHTFULLY CRAFTED. BUT I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT THE
PERFECT BILL. I DO NOT BELIEVE
THE SENSITIVE RECEPTOR SETBACKS
IN THIS BILL ADEQUATELY PROTECT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THESE, HOWEVER, ARE ONLY A
MINIMUM AND NOTHING IN THIS BILL
STOPS CITIES OR ADVOCATES FOR
PUSHING TO PUT IN PLACE STRONGER
STANDARDS WITH LOCAL CITIES AND
COUNTIES. THIS BILL DOES HAVE
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS, HOWEVER,
THAT MOVE OUR COMMUNITY FORWARD.
AB 98 PUTS IN PLACE 21ST CENTURY
BUILDING STANDARDS FOR NEW
WAREHOUSES. IT PROHIBITS HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCK AISLES FROM
BEING ADJACENT TO A SENSITIVE
RECEPTOR PROPERTY LINE. AB 98
PUTS IN PLACE A MANDATORY UPDATE
OF TRUCK ROUTES STATEWIDE TO
ENSURE TRUCKS DO NOT ROUTE
THEMSELVES THROUGH RESIDENTIAL
STREETS IN OUR COMMUNITIES. AB
98 REQUIRES A TWO FOR ONE
REPLACEMENT FOR HOMES DEMOLISHED
IN ORDER TO MAKE ROOM FOR MORE
LOGISTICS DEVELOPMENT, AND 12
MONTHS PAYMENT FOR DISPLACED
RENTERS. AB 98 PUTS IN PLACE
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY LINE
BUFFERS FOR NEW WAREHOUSES. AB
98 INCLUDES AN INTERIM REPORT IN
2028 THAT ALLOWS FOR US TO TRACK
OUR PROGRESS IN REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND TO EVALUATE OUR
NEXT STEPS. WE HAVE IMPORTANT
PARTNERS AND AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS
INDICATED, IT APPEARS THAT ALL
OF OUR PARTNERS, IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER, ARE UNHAPPY WITH THE
FINAL RESULT. THIS HAS BEEN A
DIFFICULT PROCESS, BUT A VERY
IMPORTANT ONE. AND WHAT WE HAVE
BEFORE US IN AB 98 REPRESENTS A
COMPROMISE THAT PROVIDES FOR
BOTH PROTECTIONS OF JOBS AND
SOME STANDARDS THAT ARE GOING TO
HELP AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITY, WHILE
NOT STOPPING THE INDUSTRY
ALTOGETHER. IN SUMMARY, THERE IS
STILL WORK TO BE DONE, AND I
BELIEVE PASSING AB 98 IS A PART
OF THIS WORK. THIS IS A FIRST
STEP, NOT THE LAST. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH EVERYONE
ON THE WORK AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
SUPPORT WITNESSES. SO IF OUR TWO
SUPPORT WITNESSES WOULD COME UP
HERE. GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS, JOE CRUZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE LABORERS INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF NORTH AMERICA, REPRESENTING
80,000 HARD WORKING CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA,
MANY WHO WORK DIRECTLY IN THE
INDUSTRIAL WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY.
AND I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT AB 98
TODAY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CARRILLO AND REYES, WHO SHARE MY
PASSION FOR THE COMMUNITY AND
WORKERS. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
MONTHS, THE LABORERS HAVE WORKED
TIRELESSLY IN GOOD FAITH WITH
MANY KEY STAKEHOLDERS, ALONG
WITH LEADERSHIP IN IDENTIFYING A
PRAGMATIC AND BALANCED APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING AIR QUALITY
CONCERNS IN THOSE VERY
COMMUNITIES. VÌ MEMBERS WORKING,
BUT ALSO PROTECTING THOUSANDS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS. THE LABORERS
HAVE SPENT YEARS ORGANIZING THE
WAREHOUSE, TILT UP INDUSTRY,
ESPECIALLY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY, WHERE
AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN HARDEST HIT
BY UNEMPLOYMENT. SO WE'RE
PROVIDING A REALLY GOOD, PATHWAY
TO THE MIDDLE CLASS BY BUILDING
THESE WAREHOUSES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, CALIFORNIA'S PORTS AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS ARE
CRITICAL FOR LOCAL, STATE AND
OUR NATIONAL ECONOMIES, AND IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE COME UP WITH
A COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION THAT
IMPROVES THE ENVIRONMENT,
CONTINUES TO GROW. CALIFORNIA,
THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND SUPPORTS GOODS
MOVEMENT, WHICH IS KEY TO OUR
VERY LONG TERM ECONOMIC HEALTH.
AB 98 BRINGS INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS TO TACKLE IMMEDIATE
AIR QUALITY, SAFETY AND SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES, WHILE ALSO
BRINGING BUILDING STANDARDS THAT
PROMOTE A REAL, GREEN, CLEAN
21ST CENTURY WAREHOUSE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE WORK ASSOCIATED
WITH THE INDUSTRIAL WAREHOUSE
CONSTRUCTION HAS PROVIDED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOUSANDS OF
HARDWORKING LABORERS TO PURCHASE
HOMES WHERE THEY WORK TO BUILD
FOR THEIR FAMILY'S FUTURE, AND
TO LIVE TO AGAIN IN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY WORK IN
AND RESIDE FOR YEARS. AB 90. AB
98 IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT
COMPROMISE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW THE STATE'S ECONOMY AND
DRIVE DOWN POVERTY. THERE WILL
BE MANY GROUPS WHO STAND UP
TODAY TO OPPOSE THIS BILL, WHO
SAY IT DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH.
THERE WILL BE MANY GROUPS WHO
OPPOSE THIS BILL WHO SAYS IT
GOES TOO FAR, BUT I SIT HERE
RIGHT NOW AND ASK YOU
RESPECTFULLY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT'S FAIR. IT'S
FAIR FOR WORKERS. IT'S FAIR FOR
BUSINESSES AND IT'S FAIR FOR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JOSE
GREENWALD HERE ON BEHALF OF UFCW
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 98.
RESEARCH HAS WELL DOCUMENTED THE
NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
HEALTH IMPACTS OF WAREHOUSING.
THE DIESEL EXHAUST FROM
LOGISTICS HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
WORSENING AIR QUALITY,
ESPECIALLY IN SAN BERNARDINO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTY, WHICH HAVE TWO
OF THE WORST LEVELS OF OZONE IN
THE UNITED STATES. RESIDENTS OF
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY HAVE
REPORTED HIGHER LEVELS OF
ASTHMA, WITH THE MAJORITY OF
CENSUS TRACKS IN THE CITY OF SAN
BERNARDINO HAVING ASTHMA RATES
70 TO 96%, HIGHER THAN THAT OF
OTHER CENSUS TRACKS IN
CALIFORNIA. ACROSS THESE TWO
COUNTIES, THERE ARE OVER 4.6
MILLION AT RISK INDIVIDUALS
BEING EXPOSED TO UNHEALTHY
LEVELS OF OZONE AND PARTICLE
POLLUTION. EACH AND EVERY DAY.
THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
WAREHOUSING DEVELOPMENT IS NOW
BEING FELT BY COMMUNITIES AND
WORKERS ALL OVER THE STATE, NOT
JUST IN THE INLAND EMPIRE. THESE
IMPACTS ARE COMPOUNDED BY THE
FACT THAT WAREHOUSING IS BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY SITED NEXT TO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE OFTEN
WORKING CLASS LATINO AND BLACK
COMMUNITIES, OLDER ADULTS AND
THOSE LIVING WITH PREEXISTING
HEALTH CONDITIONS. OUR MEMBERS,
IT IS UNJUST TO PLACE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH BURDEN ON HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, WHO
ARE SEEING A STAGGERING DECLINE
IN THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE WHEN
THESE FACILITIES ARE SITED NEXT
TO THEIR HOMES, SCHOOLS, PARKS
AND OTHER SENSITIVE RECEPTORS.
AB 98 IMPLEMENTS A STATEWIDE
FRAMEWORK THAT DETERS THE
DEMOLITION OF HOUSING FOR
WAREHOUSE DEVELOPMENT, REQUIRES
BUILDING STANDARDS THAT PROMOTE
WORKER SAFETY AND SETS A FLOOR
OF STANDARDS FOR WAREHOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND EXPANSION THAT
ALLOWS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
STRENGTHEN THIS BILL. WHILE NOT
PERFECT MOVES CALIFORNIA IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS
PROTECTING OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES, BUT MORE WORK IS
STILL NEEDED. WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE FURTHER PROTECTIONS ARE
NEEDED UNDER THIS FRAMEWORK FOR
LOGISTICS FACILITIES SMALLER
THAN 250,000FT² AND STRONGER
SETBACK LIMITS FOR SENSITIVE
RECEPTORS. ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
MORE WORK IS NEEDED, WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO ESTABLISH A
BASELINE STANDARD OF PROTECTIONS
FROM WAREHOUSE DEVELOPMENT FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. THAT
IS WHY WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY ON AB 98. PERFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, OKAY. WE
WILL MOVE ON NOW TO HEARING,
YES, YES, SUPPORT. SO IF
EVERYONE WHO IS IN SUPPORT, IF
YOU WOULD GO UP TO THE
MICROPHONE, AND IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND WHERE AND IF YOU'RE
SUPPORTING, JUST CLARIFY THAT
YOU ARE SUPPORTING. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. TODD. HOLD ON JUST
ONE SECOND. OKAY. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR TODD
BLUMSTEIN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MATT CREMEANS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. KEITH
DUNN, ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRONWORKERS, AS WELL
AS THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT. WE APPRECIATE YOUR HARD
WORK AND YEARS OF DEDICATION.
MANY LEÓN CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR JOBS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MARK FAROOQ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT.
MORNING, MELANIE PERRON ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
MORNING, DON MADI FOR BNSF
RAILWAY IN SUPPORT. THIS MORNING
FAITH CONLEY WITH WYOMING GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
COUNCIL, WE ARE WIENER. WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AS
WE MOVE FORWARD ON POTENTIAL
CLEANUP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ADAM WRIGLEY, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
WE HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION. WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
COMPROMISE ADVANCED. THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS, FRANK
MOLINA, ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
MANUEL BAND OF MISSION AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. RYAN ELAINE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION, WE HAVE A NEUTRAL
POSITION AS WELL IN ORDER TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MATT
SUTTON WITH THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. WE TOO ARE NEUTRAL.
OUR SUPPLIER NETWORK IS LARGE
AND VAST AND IS INTERESTED IN
SEEING A COMPROMISE ON THIS
ISSUE. SO THEY DO BELIEVE AB 98
REPRESENTS THAT. AND IF WE CAN
GET CLOSER TO COMPROMISE, THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET. SO
WE'RE NOT QUITE IN SUPPORT, BUT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET THERE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NICK CAMMARATA,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION,
WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU. DEBORAH CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE ALSO
NEUTRAL. THANK YOU. OKAY ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? OKAY. SEEING
NONE. OPPOSITION. OKAY AND, AS I
HAVE IT, HERE IS THE TWO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
WOULD COME UP FRONT, ANDREA, VIA
D¯ÚI. DODD VIA DODD. WELCOME.
AND, MARK BERGER. OKAY WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. YES. OKAY GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ANDREA VIDAK. I'M WITH
THE PEOPLE'S COLLECTIVE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. WHILE I
GREATLY RESPECT THE WORK THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO AND REYES
HAVE DONE TO UPLIFT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
WAREHOUSE DEVELOPMENT, I MUST
URGE YOUR NO VOTE ON AB 98. I
LIVE AND WORK WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND WORKERS IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE, WHO ARE THE MOST
IMPACTED BY WAREHOUSE
DEVELOPMENT, SOME OF WHOM ARE
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION. EVERY
DAY WE DEAL WITH THE IMPACTS OF
HARMFUL LAND USE DECISIONS FROM
WAREHOUSING, SUCH AS THE OVER
100 DAYS OUT OF THE YEAR. IT IS
UNSAFE TO BREATHE OUTSIDE THE
ALL TOO CONSTANT PEDESTRIAN
ACCIDENTS AND FATALITIES FROM
TRUCK ROUTES BEING TOO CLOSE TO
HOMES AND SCHOOLS, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THE LOOMING THREAT
THAT OUR LIFE EXPECTANCY IS AT
RISK OF BEING CUT SHORT BECAUSE
OF WHERE WE LIVE. INSTEAD OF
ADDRESSING THE CUMULATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF WAREHOUSE DEVELOPMENT
AND BAD LAND USE, THIS BILL
SEEKS TO SET ARBITRARY SETBACKS
DISTANCES SET FROM THIN AIR THAT
RESEARCH AT CARB SHOWS IS
INSUFFICIENT TO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH. THIS IS, AMONG OTHER
ISSUES THAT WE THINK COULD HAVE
BEEN IMPROVED IN THE BILL IF WE
WERE GIVEN A CHANCE TO PROVIDE
INPUT. WE BELIEVE THAT USHERING
IN A BILL AT THE 11TH HOUR, WITH
NO OPPORTUNITY FOR COMMUNITY
INPUT, IS THE WRONG AND UNJUST
WAY OF ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE. WE
HAVE FOUGHT COUNTLESS WAREHOUSES
FROM COMING INTO THE BACKYARDS
OF COMMUNITY MEMBERS, WHICH MANY
OF THEM FOUGHT OR ARE FIGHTING
FOR SETBACKS LARGER THAN THE
INADEQUATE SETBACKS THAT THIS
BILL WOULD DEEM LEGAL. THIS IS
NOT A REASONABLE COMPROMISE
BETWEEN GROUPS. THIS IS A BILL.
THIS BILL IS A RESULT OF CLOSED
DOOR PROCESS THAT LEFT OUT
CRITICAL COMMUNITY VOICES. THE
STRIKING LIST OF OPPOSITION IS
EVIDENCE OF THE DISCONNECT TO
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL.
ACCORDING TO THE AUTHORS, THIS
LAW WILL HARM OUR LOCAL
ORGANIZING WORK TO PUSH FOR
STRONGER HEALTH, PROTECTIVE LAND
USE POLICIES BY GREENLIGHTING
BUSINESS AS USUAL AS AN
ACCEPTABLE PRACTICE. WE DON'T.
WE WANT TO SEE COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS TO WAREHOUSING THAT
INCLUDES COMMUNITY INPUT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON AB 98.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD SIR. GOOD
MORNING. MARK NEUBERGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES, ALSO PROVIDING REMARKS
ON BEHALF OF CAL CITIES. OUR
MAJOR CONCERN, FIRST OFF IS THAT
AB 98 WAS INTRODUCED FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE FINAL DAYS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION AFTER
MONTHS OF EXCLUSIVE CLOSED DOOR
NEGOTIATIONS, WHICH EXCLUDED CAL
CITIES AND OTHER RELEVANT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ASSOCIATIONS AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS. WELL, THE BILL'S
INTENTIONS ARE AIMED AT
ADDRESSING AIR QUALITY AND
RELATED CONCERNS ADJACENT TO
WAREHOUSE OPERATIONS. ITS
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS WILL
SEVERELY IMPACT THE ABILITY OF
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO SITE
BASED ON UNIQUE GEOGRAPHIC AND
COMMUNITY CHARACTERISTICS, WHICH
IS THE GUIDING THOUGHT PROCESS
BEHIND LOCAL CONTROL, ALLOWING
LOCAL LEADERS TO ADOPT
DEVELOPMENT TO LOCAL REALITIES
AND LIMITATIONS. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN RURAL
SETTINGS, WHERE AGRICULTURAL
LOGISTICS CENTERS AND WAREHOUSES
WILL BE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL
AND HAVE A DIFFERENT SET OF
CONCERNS THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ADDRESS. HOWEVER, THIS BILL MAY
EITHER CONFLICT OR CREATE NEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE PROJECTS
THAT DON'T MAKE ANY SENSE IN
RURAL SETTINGS. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO LIKELY STIFLE ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PLANS THAT
HAVE BEEN DEVELOPED IN THESE
COMMUNITIES, WITH COMMUNITY
INPUT. AB 98 ALSO OVERRIDES
EXISTING GOOD NEIGHBOR POLICIES
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE
DEVELOPED, WHERE LOCALS HAVE
DETERMINED APPROPRIATE SETBACK
REQUIREMENTS AND CONDITIONS FOR
LOGISTIC USE. DEVELOPMENTS BASED
ON SPECIFIC GEOGRAPHIC AND
REGIONAL FACTORS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES, AND WOULD ALSO
ALLOW LOCAL AND IT ALSO HAS BEEN
ALLOWED THROUGH LOCAL
GOVERNANCE, THE ABILITY TO
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC TO DEVELOP
THESE GOOD NEIGHBOR POLICIES. WE
BELIEVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SHOULD
RETAIN THE ABILITY TO EXERCISE
LOCAL DISCRETION WHEN SITING
LOGISTICS. LOCAL LOGISTIC USE
DEVELOPMENTS PRIOR TO ANY STATE
MANDATED CONDITIONS BEING
PROVIDED. AS THIS BILL WOULD
PROVIDE. MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES WOULD NOT ALSO NOT WANT
TO ENCOURAGE SITING, HOUSING OR
OTHER CONFLICTING USES WITH
LOGISTICS CENTER, WHICH THIS
BILL ALLOWS FOR THE CO-LOCATION
OF THESE CONFLICTING USES TO GET
OUT OF THE BILL'S PROVISIONS. I
ALSO WANT TO TOUCH ON THE
CIRCULATION ELEMENT AND
ENFORCEMENT. AB 98 THRUSTS AN
EXTENSIVE CIRCULATION ELEMENT
UPDATE REQUIREMENT ON ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH NO REGARD FOR THE ACTUAL
DEVELOPMENT OF LOGISTIC USE.
WAREHOUSES IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE LOOKING AT BEING REQUIRED TO
UPDATE FOUR ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS
UNRELATED TO THIS BILL IN THE
SAME TIME FRAME, WHICH IS
UNREALISTIC, AND WE BELIEVE,
UNREASONABLE. FURTHER, MANY OF
THE TRUCK ROUTE PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL MAY VIOLATE EXISTING
FEDERAL REGULATIONS FOCUSED ON
PROHIBITING LOCAL BARRIERS TO
INTERSTATE COMMERCE, ACTIVITIES
THAT MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS ARE ENGAGED IN. THANK
YOU. OKAY, OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY. EVERYONE, IN
OPPOSITION, WHO WISHES TO COME
FORWARD AGAIN, PLEASE, GIVE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION. HOLD ON
JUST ONE SECOND. SO WE CAN GET
SOME FOLKS LAWCENTER.
OKAY. GO AHEAD, GET STARTED.
SIR. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. LAWRENCE VALENCIA
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE ALSO, RESPECTFULLY, IN
OPPOSITION. I WOULD ECHO MY
COMMENT, THE COMMENTS RAISED BY
MY COLLEAGUE AT CSAC,
PARTICULARLY ON THE CIRCULATION
ELEMENT. OUR MEMBERS WILL BE
CHARGED WITH IMPLEMENTING THE
BILL. SO JUST REALLY HAVE
CONCERNS ON THAT IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. OKAY. I JUST
WANT TO REMIND EVERYBODY, JUST
YOUR NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
WHERE YOU STAND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF
OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. TRICIA
AMERON, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
ONTARIO IN OPPOSITION. MAX
PERRY, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
RIALTO, ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
MELISSA SPARKS KRANZ WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, AS
WELL AS THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. CASSANDRA MÀ, ON
BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
MARK FENSTERMAKER, ON BEHALF OF
EARTHJUSTICE, RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION. HORACIO GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE, IN
OPPOSITION. ANDREW MENDOZA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. JOSH GALLAGHER, ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA, IN OPPOSITION.
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. KAREN LANG, ON BEHALF
OF THE KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. CHAIR
MEMBERS. DANE HUTCHINGS, IN
OPPOSITION, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA,
CORONA, EASTVALE, BEAUMONT,
MERCED. AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO PROVIDE OPPOSITION ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
DANIEL CONWAY, CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION, ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS ROSS BUCKLEY, ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION, WITH YOUR
PERMISSION, DO YOU MIND IF I SAY
A LITTLE BIT MORE SO YOU CAN'T.
SORRY OTHERWISE WE'D HAVE TO
GIVE IT TO EVERYBODY. THANK YOU.
ESMERALDA TAVARES WITH CONCERNED
NEIGHBORS OF BLOOMINGTON IN
OPPOSITION. AUDREY RATAJCZAK, ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SKYLAR WONACOTT, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION, BOMA,
CALIFORNIA. AND NH█P, CALIFORNIA.
IN OPPOSITION, GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS. ROB SPIEGEL, CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION ASHA SHARMA ON BEHALF
OF COMMUNITIES FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT, CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE, CLEAN AIR
FOR KIDS, AND SIERRA CLUB IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ALONDRA. MATEO ON
BEHALF OF UNITED FOR COLTON,
ROBERT REDFORD CONSERVANCY AND
FOCUS NUEVO IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING, DANIELA VARGAS HERE
WITH CONCERNED NEIGHBORS OF
BLOOMINGTON IN OPPOSITION.
HELLO, CARLOS CERVANTES ON
BEHALF OF MID-VALLEY COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR, INLAND VALLEY
ALLIANCE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE, PARIS NEIGHBORS IN
ACTION, RIVERSIDE NEIGHBORS
OPPOSING WAREHOUSES, WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. TANYA GONZALEZ. ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE'S
COLLECTIVE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE, WAREHOUSE WORKERS
RESOURCE CENTER, EAST YARD
COMMUNITIES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE, YUCAIPA VALLEY
CONSERVANCY, AND SAVE YUCAIPA.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WELL.
THANK YOU. HOLA. MI NOMBRE ES
ANA VENGO DE SAN BERNARDINO. INO
VALLAPUDUA ESTÁ LA GRACIAS. HI.
MY NAME IS ANA. I'M FROM SAN
BERNARDINO, AND I DON'T APPROVE
THIS BILL. BUENOS DIAS. MI
NOMBRE ES JOSE SOLORZANO. Y
ESTOY EN CONTRA TAMBIÉN DE ESTA
PROPUESTA. GRACIAS. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS JOSE
SOLORZANO, AND I'M ALSO AGAINST
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. KATIE VALENZUELA WITH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION, ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE NETWORK AND THE CARBON
CYCLE INSTITUTE. IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
CATHERINE GAROUPA ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AIR QUALITY
COALITION CENTER ON RACE,
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND
CLEAN WATER ACTION IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING, SENATORS MATTHEW
BAKER, PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
LEAGUE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN OPPOSITION. PHOEBE
SEATON, WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL,
ALSO ON BEHALF OF PSR LÀ, FRESNO
BUILDING HEALTHY COMMUNITIES AND
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA ASTHMA
COALITION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. JONATHAN PRUITT, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE,
THE COALITION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
EQUITY AND ECONOMICS, AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COALITION
FOR WATER, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION TOBIAS WILKIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION SHARON GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BAKERSFIELD, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION? OKAY. SEEING
NONE, BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE
MEMBERS FOR YOUR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS, WE WANT TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. SENATORS DURAZZO.
DURAZZO, PRESENT SEYARTO SEYARTO
PRESENT. DOLLY. DOLLY. PRESENT.
GLASER. GLASER. PRESENT.
SKINNER. SKINNER PRESENT. WAHAB.
WAHAB. PRESENT WIENER. WIENER.
PRESENT. YOU HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY I'LL
OPEN UP TO OUR MEMBERS HERE. MY
COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? Ó. SENATOR WIENER.
SORRY THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
FIRST OF ALL, I MOVE THE BILL, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHORS. AND I
KNOW, ESPECIALLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES. I KNOW YOU FOR YEARS THIS
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING ISSUE. AND
AND I'VE WATCHED IT, IT'S
ACTUALLY COME TO, WELL, THE
PREDECESSOR OF THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE AND, AND ULTIMATELY, IT
WASN'T ABLE TO, TO MOVE. AND I
KNOW THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY HARD
ISSUE, AND IT'S ALWAYS I KNOW,
SORT OF AN INTERESTING SITUATION
WHEN YOU HAVE THE, YOU KNOW,
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE AND
EARTHJUSTICE TESTIFYING BACK TO
BACK AGAINST YOUR BILL. AND IT
IS THE BILL. THIS BILL IS A
COMPROMISE. AND THERE ARE FOLKS
ON BOTH SIDES WHO ARE UNHAPPY
WITH THAT. AND I COMPLETELY
RESPECT THAT. THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLY HARD ISSUE IN TERMS
OF HOW DO WE HAVE A FUNCTIONING
SYSTEM OF WAREHOUSES AND THAT
ECONOMY, AND ALSO PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH? AND I THINK YOU'RE
TRYING TO NAVIGATE THAT.
OBVIOUSLY, NOT EVERYONE AGREES
WITH IT, BUT I COMMEND YOU FOR
DOING THAT WORK, AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. AND
AGAIN, I MOVE THE BILL. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU, I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO BOTH OF YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS, IT IS
PROGRESS. IT WILL IMPROVE THE
CIRCUMSTANCE IN TERMS OF AIR
QUALITY IN THE AREA, AND AGAIN,
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAID, AND I THINK YOU
PROBABLY DID, THOUGH I WASN'T
ABLE TO HEAR YOUR OPENING, IT
WASN'T EVERYTHING THAT YOU
WANTED. HOWEVER, IT IS PROGRESS.
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK IS HARD
FOR SOME OF US. IT IS LEGITIMATE
TO BE CONCERNED. WELL, IF WE
MOVE ON, THIS WILL THAT FREEZE
IT AT THIS? WILL THERE NEVER BE
ANY FURTHER MOTION? BUT
ACTUALLY, IN MY EXPERIENCE, AND
THIS IS NOW THE END OF MY 14
YEARS IN THE LEGISLATURE, WHILE
I'M NOT SOMEONE WHO NECESSARILY
LIKES INCREMENTAL, IT OFTEN HAS
TO HAPPEN THAT WAY AND THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE PROGRESS AND THEN
LET THAT PROGRESS, LET IT SHOW
HOW IT'S WORKING OR NOT WORKING.
AND THEN WE MAKE ADDITIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS OR CHANGES. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE SPIRIT THAT YOU
HAVE, DONE THIS AND WITH THAT I
WILL ALSO BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU, I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO UNDERSTAND
THE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS IN DEVELOPING THIS
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE. YOU KNOW, I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT MANY
OF THE OPPOSITION FOLKS HAVE
STATED THAT THEY WERE NOT
INVOLVED IN THE CONVERSATION,
SPECIFICALLY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUP. SO I'D LIKE TO
HEAR. WELL, THERE WAS A
WAREHOUSE WORKING GROUP THAT
WAS, ON THE TABLE FROM FROM BOTH
SIDES. AND I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
FEELING THAT NOT EVERYBODY WAS
ALLOWED BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE.
BUT THIS ISSUE, AS BOTH OF YOU
MENTIONED, AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES KNOWS, VERY WELL, IT'S
BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS FOR YEARS.
WE HAD TO TAKE AN APPROACH WHERE
WE HAD A WORKING GROUP. THAT
WORKING GROUP WAS ON THE TABLE
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS THE EJ
COMMUNITY. AND IF THE
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WANTS TO
ELABORATE, I'LL AND WHO FROM THE
EJ COMMUNITIES WERE INVOLVED,
FROM WHAT COMMUNITY? THE
COMMUNITY. YEAH. YOU STATED IT.
RIGHT. SO WHO ON THAT YOUR LIST
WAS INVOLVED? DO YOU KNOW BETTER
THAN COMMUNITY THAN I DO?
KAMLAGER COUNTY VOTERS. CAL
VOTERS. OKAY. AND THAT WAS THE
ONLY GROUP I BELIEVE SO. OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. BUT I'M SORRY.
THROUGH THE CHAIR. THANK YOU.
OKAY. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
SORRY. FIRST TIME, I, I DON'T
BELIEVE CAL ENVIRO VOTERS
REPRESENTS ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE,
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES. SO I AND
THERE WERE ZERO ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES THAT
REPRESENT NEIGHBORHOODS IN THAT
COMMITTEE. OKAY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES, DO YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT? I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS. IF YOU COULD RESPOND TO
MY COLLEAGUE'S QUESTION, I,
INITIALLY I WAS NOT PART OF THE
WORKGROUP. ALSO THE THERE WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO INCLUDE BUSINESS.
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO INCLUDE
LABOR AND THE REPRESENTATIVE FOR
CAL ENVIRO VOTERS, JENNA PRICE
ALSO COMMUNICATED PERHAPS
LIMITED IN A LIMITED WAY, BUT
COMMUNICATED WITH CEJA
COMMUNICATED WITH EJ GROUPS,
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE'S
COLLECTIVE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE, IN A LIMITED WAY, AND
ALSO CAGE SPECIFICALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITY. I DON'T KNOW WHICH
OTHERS. OKAY AND THE REASON WHY
I ASK AND I UNDERSTAND JUST ONE
SECOND, COULD YOU LET ME LET ME
LET ME. OKAY. GO AHEAD. WAS THE
NAME OF IF YOU COULD SAY WHAT IT
STANDS FOR. YOU KNOW, I. I KNOW
IT'S FOR COMMUNITIES, FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. THEY ARE
THE GROUP THAT HAD BEEN HERE
DURING THE LAST HEARINGS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. AND I AM
ABSOLUTELY I'M SORRY THAT I
CANNOT REMEMBER THE ACRONYM,
WHAT THE ACRONYM MEANS, BUT IT
IS THE LONGEST STANDING
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUP IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE, WHICH IS,
ALONG WITH THE PEOPLE'S
COLLECTIVE FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND SO MANY OTHERS THAT
HAVE FOUGHT TIRELESSLY FOR THE
COMMUNITY. OKAY, LET'S GO BACK.
SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU, THE
REASON WHY I SPEAK ABOUT THIS,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW,
COMPROMISE AS OUR SENATOR,
STATED, IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY ON DIFFICULT ISSUES,
ESPECIALLY FOR TRYING TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES, ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I'M CONCERNED IS BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, I REPRESENT A LARGE
COMMUNITY OF COLOR. AND
OFTENTIMES THE FOLKS IN THE
NEIGHBORS THAT LIVE IN THE
SURROUNDING AREAS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO GOVERN, ARE NOT PART
OF THAT CONVERSATION. AND MANY
OF THEM, ESPECIALLY COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR SLASH IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES, DON'T EVEN KNOW
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING.
RIGHT? SO THERE IS A LACK OF
ENGAGEMENT TO BEGIN WITH, THAT
IS PROBLEMATIC FOR ME, AND I DO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT ALSO, THE
FACT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ARE ALSO HERE AND
SPECIFICALLY IN MY DISTRICT, YOU
KNOW, D10 HAS, YOU KNOW, DOZENS
OF MANUFACTURERS THAT WOULD HAVE
TO WOULD BE ENCOMPASSED IN THIS
BILL, AND YET THEY WEREN'T
CONSULTED IN THIS BILL AS WELL.
AND JUST IN THE ONE OF MY MAIN
CITIES OF FREMONT, WE HAVE 900
MANUFACTURERS IN MY CITY, MORE
THAN ANY OTHER CITY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. RIGHT. AND WHEN
YOU HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
GROUPS AS WELL AS, YOU KNOW, THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND SO FORTH,
I STILL BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
WORK TO BE DONE. THAT IS MY
CONCERN, NOT A BIG FAN OF
INCREMENTAL CHANGE. I LIKE TO,
YOU KNOW, MAKE SURE THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE MOVING THE BALL
FORWARD. AND I ALSO REALLY VALUE
THE COMMUNITY VOICE. RIGHT. THAT
WAS CLEARLY NOT AT THE TABLE, I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL OUT
OF HERE. BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS AS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD AND SOME
CLEANUP DONE. I KNOW THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE WORKED WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS. I KNOW
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT LAST MINUTE
PUT ON OUR PLATE, AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S NECESSARILY FAIR,
BUT, I WILL CONTINUE THE PROCESS
AND THE DIALOG FOR YOU GUYS. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE? SENATOR SOLANO. SORRY. CAN
YOU. YEAH. OKAY. SO THERE IS A
LOT TO UNPACK HERE. I'VE SAT IN
THE HOUSE WITH YOU WHILE YOU
TRIED TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IN
THE LAST THREE YEARS, AND THERE
ARE REASONS WHY IT DIDN'T GET
FURTHER, BUT TWO DAYS BEFORE END
OF SESSION TO APPROPRIATELY
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT ARE
RAISED BY THESE AMENDMENTS, IN A
COMMITTEE HEARING THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE DONE IN TEN
MINUTES IS NOT AN APPROPRIATE
FORUM FOR THE COMPLEXITY OF THIS
ISSUE. I HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION. IT KIND OF FOLLOWS UP
ON HER WHAT CAL CITY
REPRESENTATIVE AND WHAT CSAC
REPRESENTATIVE WERE PART OF THE
WORKING GROUP. CAN YOU GIVE ME
THEIR NAMES? THANK YOU. WE
CONSULTED WITH SEVERAL GROUPS
OUT OF THE WORKING TABLE, BACK
AND FORTH THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. THIS WAS PUT IN PLACE
SINCE MARCH. WHAT PART OF WHO ON
CAL CITIES AND WHO IN CSAC?
BECAUSE BECAUSE I WAS PART OF
CAL CITIES AT ONE TIME. I WAS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE MAYORS AND
COUNCILS. SO I WOULD EXPECT
THAT, ME OR SOMEBODY WE KNEW
ASSOCIATED WITH SOMEBODY
REPRESENTING OUR CITIES OR BEING
AFFECTED BY THIS WOULD BE AT
THAT TABLE TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE
WITH YOU. IS THAT DID THAT
HAPPEN OR WERE THEY NOT CITIES?
SPECIFIC CITIES WERE NOT ON THE
TABLE? NO. THERE WERE NO CITY
REPRESENTATION COUNTIES BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF UNINCORPORATED
AREAS THAT ARE HAVING THIS TYPE
OF GROWTH. YOU KNOW, SPECIFIC
CITIES OR COUNTIES WERE AT THE
TABLE. NO. OKAY. SO THEY WERE
NOT AT THE TABLE. I THINK YOU'VE
ASKED IT A FEW TIMES. SO ANY
MORE QUESTIONS? YEAH, I HAVE A
LOT OF QUESTIONS. IF WE'RE GOING
TO DISCUSS THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
IN A REGION THAT I LIVE IN AND I
GREW UP IN. YES, I HAVE A LOT TO
SAY ABOUT THIS BECAUSE AS FAR AS
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS, THANK YOU.
WELL, THEY'RE NOT SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS. THEY'RE ALSO
COMMENTS. OKAY. THIS INVOLVES
THE HOUSING ELEMENT. IT IT
INVOLVES THE CIRCULATION ELEMENT
CHANGE. IT INVOLVES PUBLIC
SAFETY. IT INVOLVES ALL OF THOSE
THINGS. AND WE'RE PUTTING ON
CITIES TO TRY TO GET THIS DONE.
AND IN OUR AREA IN RIVERSIDE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BY 2026,
OR THEY'RE GOING TO GET $50,000
FINES. IS THAT CORRECT? EVERY
SIX MONTHS IN MY AREA? YES, THAT
IS CORRECT. OKAY. YOU'RE YOU'RE
A PLANNER. YES. YOU'VE WORKED
FOR CITIES. YES SIR. WHEN CITIES
ARE COMPETING FOR THE SAME
PEOPLE TO TRY TO UPDATE THEIR
GENERAL PLANS, BECAUSE WHEN YOU
HAVE THESE CIRCULATION ELEMENT
CHANGES, EVERYTHING ELSE CHANGES
TOO. AND YOU HAVE TO DO A
GENERAL PLAN UPDATE THOSE
GENERAL PLAN UPDATES COST
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN COUNCIL,
YOU KNOW, IN FEES BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO ALSO DO A NEW SQL
ENVIRONMENT DOCUMENT. SO THERE'S
A BUNCH OF STUFF THAT GOES WITH
THAT. AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
HAVING THIS DONE BY 2026, WHICH
IS IN IN 18 MONTHS. I HAVE I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN A LOT OF THESE.
I'VE NOT SEEN ONE THAT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND AND SO THAT
THAT SURPRISES ME THAT WE THINK
WE CAN GET THIS DONE. AND THEN
START FINDING CITIES $50,000
EVERY SIX MONTHS BECAUSE THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET IT DONE. SO
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE I HAVE WITH
THIS, THE AIR QUALITY ISSUES IN
THAT REGION FOR SOMEBODY THAT
ACTUALLY GREW UP THERE. AND HAVE
A FULL UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT
WAS VERSUS WHAT IT IS NOW, IT
WAS A WHOLE LOT WORSE WHEN I
GREW UP THERE, AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE A BUNCH OF WAREHOUSES. THE
REASON IT IS SO BAD OUT THERE IS
BECAUSE THE AIR, THE PREVAILING
WINDS, BLOW ALL OF THE SMOG FROM
THE BASIN, THE LA BASIN, THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BASIN INTO
THAT REGION. AND IT TRAPS AND
THE MOUNTAINS TRAP IT THERE. AND
WE HAVE AN INVERSION LAYER THAT
TRAPS IT THERE. THAT'S WHY OUR
AIR QUALITY IS SO BAD. SO YES,
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING OVER THE LAST
20 YEARS OR 40 YEARS TO FIX
THAT, I FORGOT HOW OLD I AM, AND
IT IS A LOT BETTER THAN IT USED
TO BE. BUT IF THIS IS ALL HINGED
ON THE DIESEL PARTICULATE, WE'RE
GETTING RID OF THE DIESEL. SO
WHY WOULD WE GO THROUGH ALL OF
THESE CHANGES AND MAKE ALL THESE
RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT COMMUNITIES
CAN DO IF THE DIESEL PART OF
THIS IS GOING TO GO AWAY IN JUST
A FEW YEARS HERE, BECAUSE
BECAUSE ALL THESE INDUSTRIES ARE
SPENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
UPDATING THEIR STUFF SO THAT
THEY CAN GET RID OF THE DIESEL.
SO IF THE DIESEL IS NOT THERE,
THEN WHAT PART OF THE AIR
PARTICULATE ENVIRONMENT ARE WE
BASING SOME OF THESE THESE
REGULATIONS ON? THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT YOU FEEL THAT THE AIR
QUALITY IS THE BEST. THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION DOES
THEIR STUDIES. WE'VE BEEN
RECEIVING THE AWARD NOT JUST SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY BUT RIVERSIDE
COUNTY FOR THE WORST POLLUTION
AREAS IN AMERICA. THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN JUST BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
VALLEY. THAT'S ONE OF THE
FACTORS. SO BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT. I THINK THAT IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO SET THE GUARDRAILS
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT OF BUSINESS. AND I
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THAT. AND
I WANT BUSINESSES TO COME IN,
BUT I WANT US TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY HAS
TO BE ONE OF THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS. AS YOU'RE
FIGURING OUT WHAT YOUR TRUCK
ZONE, WHAT YOUR TRUCK ROUTE IS,
IF YOU'RE GOING BY THE SENSITIVE
RECEPTORS AND YOU CAN GO
ELSEWHERE, GO ELSEWHERE. SO IF
THERE HAVE BEEN SO MANY MISTAKES
MADE OVER THE YEARS, THERE HAS
TO BE A BEGINNING TO START
WRITING THAT SHIP. WE'VE GOT TO
BEGIN DOING THINGS THE RIGHT
WAY. AND IF IT CANNOT BE DONE BY
2026, AS TO THE CIRCULATION
ELEMENT, THEN THE CONVERSATIONS
HAVE TO BE DONE WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. THERE
CAN BE CLEANUP LEGISLATION,
THERE CAN BE MANY OTHER THINGS.
I'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT, BUT SOMETHING HAS TO BE
DONE. WE CANNOT CONTINUE WITH
THE STATUS QUO AND CONTINUE TO
ALLOW OUR COMMUNITIES. AND AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED, IT'S USUALLY
THE POOREST, THE IMMIGRANT, THE
BLACK, THE BROWN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE THE WAREHOUSES BUILT
RIGHT NEXT TO THEM OR WITHIN A
VERY SHORT, SHORT DISTANCE. SO
THERE IS I WANT TO MAKE A POINT
OF CLARIFICATION. I DIDN'T SEE
OUR AIR QUALITY WAS THE BEST. I
SAID IT'S THE WORST FOR A
REASON. AND I GAVE THOSE
REASONS, SO WHO BETTER TO FIGURE
OUT A TRUCK CIRCULATION ELEMENT
BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE BUILDING IN
YOUR COMMUNITY? THEN THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND THE LOCAL
PLANNERS THAT KNOW THE STREETS,
THAT KNOW THE TRAFFIC PATTERNS,
THAT KNOW ALL OF THOSE THINGS,
WHO BETTER TO DO THAT THAN THEM
WITHOUT THE STATE TELLING THEM
HOW AND WHEN AND HOW THEY HAVE
TO DO THAT, AN EXAMPLE IN OUR
DISTRICT, RIVERSIDE HAD ONE OF
THESE BIG PROJECTS, AND IT'S ON
HOLD BECAUSE THEY'RE MAKING THEM
CHANGE PART OF THAT PROJECT.
WHAT THAT SHOWS IS THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, WHETHER IT'S THE
COUNTY OR THE CITY, ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT SHOULD BE IN CHARGE
OF DETERMINING HOW THOSE GO, NOT
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE NEVER, EVER
BEEN IN OUR DISTRICT. THEY DON'T
KNOW OUR CITIES LIKE WE DO. THIS
IS A LOCAL CONTROL ISSUE. THAT'S
THAT WAS THE ISSUE THE LAST TWO
YEARS IS YOU'RE TAKING AWAY
LOCAL CONTROL. YOU'RE PUNISHING
THEM. AND TRYING TO MAKE THEM DO
SOMETHING THEY CANNOT GET DONE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT. ALL ON THE PREMISE THAT
THE DIESEL PARTICULATE IS GOING
TO KILL EVERYBODY, BUT WE'RE
GETTING RID OF THAT. SO THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME. AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S A LOT MORE TO
BE UNWRAPPED IN THIS. BUT
BECAUSE WE ARE HERE AT THE END
OF OUR SESSION AND TRYING TO
DEAL WITH SOMETHING THAT IS SO
MUCH MORE COMPLEX, AND I'M SURE
THIS IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE ONE
OF THE LAST THINGS THAT WE HAVE
TO DEAL WITH AT MIDNIGHT ON
SATURDAY NIGHT, AND I THINK IT'S
WRONG. I THINK THE PROCESS THAT
WE USE TO GET HERE IS WRONG, AND
I THINK THE PROCESS THAT WE USE
TO NEGOTIATE THIS THING WAS
WRONG. SO THAT'S ALL I HAVE FOR
THIS, I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING
THIS. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON HOW WE
CAN MAKE OUR REGION BETTER,
BECAUSE I LIVE THERE AND I WANT
IT TO BE BETTER. I LIVE THERE
TOO. BORN AND RAISED. OR WAS I?
SENATOR? I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT. I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. IT'S BEEN OBVIOUS TO
ME THROUGH THE DISCUSSIONS HERE
TODAY THAT, THERE'S BEEN A WHOLE
LOT OF FOLKS LEFT OUT. AND I
THINK THAT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
HERE WE ARE AT THE LAST OF THE
SESSION AND WE HAVE, YOU KNOW, A
COOKED DEAL, UNCOOKED, I SHOULD
SAY, AND WE'RE JAMMING IT
THROUGH. OBVIOUSLY, THE EJ
COMMUNITY HASN'T BEEN THERE. THE
COUNTIES HAVEN'T BEEN THERE.
IT'S BEEN STATED WITH THE
AUTHORS OF THE BILL THAT THEY
REALLY DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THEY
ARE. THEY'RE THEY'RE ASKING
THEIR STAFF TO WHO WAS THERE,
WHO WAS NOT THERE. SO THIS HAS
BEEN COOKED IN THE SMOKE FILLED
BACK ROOMS. AND I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
HAVE TO, AT THE LAST MINUTE DEAL
WITH THIS SITUATION, AND NOT IN
A WAY THAT IS OUT FRONT AND OPEN
TO CALIFORNIANS. SO I WILL NOT
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. OKAY. I I HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES
OR CARRILLO CAN YOU JUST IN A
SHORT VERSION, HIGHLIGHT THE KEY
CHANGES THAT YOU CONSIDER ARE
GOING TO CHANGE FROM THE STATUS
QUO? YES. THANK YOU.
THERE WILL BE NEW BUILDING
STANDARDS FOR ALL NEW WAREHOUSES
BUILT AFTER ONE ONE, 26 HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCK AISLES WILL
NOT BE ALLOWED ADJACENT TO
SENSITIVE RECEPTOR PROPERTY
LINES. MANDATORY UPDATE TRUCK
ROUTES WILL BE WILL BE REQUIRED
TO ENSURE TRUCKS DO NOT ROUTE
THEMSELVES THROUGH RESIDENTIAL
STREETS AND COMMUNITIES. IT WILL
REQUIRE A TWO FOR ONE
REPLACEMENT FOR HOMES DEMOLISHED
IN ORDER TO MAKE ROOM FOR THESE
WAREHOUSES, AND ALSO FOR THE
RENTERS WHO ARE DISPLACED TO PAY
THEM FOR 12 MONTHS. IT WILL
ADDITIONALLY HAVE A BUFFER NEXT
TO THE PROPERTY LINE NEXT TO A
SENSITIVE RECEPTOR 550FT OR
100FT, DEPENDING ON THE
MEASUREMENT OF THE OF THE
WAREHOUSE. ALTHOUGH IN SAN
BERNARDINO, RIVERSIDE COUNTY, IT
WILL ALWAYS BE 100FT. THIS WILL
INCLUDE TREES AND SHRUBBERY,
IRRIGATION A WALL TO PROTECT THE
SENSITIVE RECEPTORS, AND IT WILL
ALSO INCLUDE A AN INTERIM REPORT
SO THAT WE CAN SEE WHAT THE
PROGRESS IS. IF THIS PROGRESS IS
ENOUGH THAT THE COMMUNITY'S
HEALTH IS NOT BEING HARMED,
SOMETHING TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. BUT IF THESE
STUDIES PROVE TO US WHAT OTHERS
HAVE THAT THE COMMUNITY IS BEING
HARMED BY THIS, THEN WE DO HAVE
TO REVISIT IT. IT'S IMPORTANT
AND IT IS STATED THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE MOVEMENT AND
STORAGE OF FREIGHT AND THE
IMPACT OF THIS ACTIVITY ON
PUBLIC HEALTH AND COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE A MATTER OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN. THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IF WE ARE
CONCERNED FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS, THEN WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO PUT STANDARDS THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO ABIDE BY, AND OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES CAN LOOK AT THIS AS
A FLOOR. WE HAVE SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE DOING MORE
THAN IS LISTED HERE. AND THEY
HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO AND THEY
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO FOR THEIR
LOCAL RESIDENTS, BECAUSE EVERY
CITY IS DIFFERENT, EVERY COUNTY
IS DIFFERENT. BUT TO SET AT
LEAST A FLOOR. OKAY. THANK YOU.
AND I'D LIKE TO ASK MISS ANDREA.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE I
DIDN'T MISPRONOUNCE YOUR LAST
NAME. IF YOU COULD HIGHLIGHT,
YOU KNOW, IN A QUICK, SHORT WAY,
THE ISSUES THAT YOU THINK THAT
STILL NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. I
DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH, BUT I ASSUME THERE'S SOME
SOME OF THIS OR SOME PORTION OF
THIS THAT YOU AGREE WITH. BUT IF
YOU COULD DESCRIBE WHAT MORE
WHAT OTHER AREAS THAT YOU THINK
COULD BE IMPROVED UPON? SURE.
I'LL TRY TO GO ON THE SAME WAY
THAT ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES DID.
SO SHE MENTIONED THE BUILDING
CODE STANDARDS. MY
UNDERSTANDING, AND I WISH WE
COULD HAVE LET SOUTH COAST AQMD
TALK, BECAUSE I'M ACTUALLY
INTERESTED IN THEIR OPPOSITION
BECAUSE THEY WE HELPED PASS A
WAREHOUSE INDIRECT SOURCE RULE
YEARS AGO, WHICH ARE GOING TO
THAT ADDRESS 4000 WAREHOUSES IN
THE REGION STARTING AT
100,000FT², NOT 250,000FT² LIKE
THIS BILL DOES. AND IT DOES HAVE
BUILDING STANDARDS, AND IT DOES
PUSH THEM TO SLOWLY ELECTRIFY
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
SO I'M THAT WAS A BIG QUESTION
MARK FOR ME. LIKE, HOW DOES THIS
INTERACT WITH THAT REGULATION
AND DOES IT MAKE IT WEAKER.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE LAST THING WE
WOULD WANT BECAUSE THAT WAS ALSO
DECADES OF PEOPLE FIGHTING AT
THE AIR DISTRICT. THE OTHER PART
WAS THE TRUCK ROUTES. WE HAVE A
LOT OF COMMUNITIES ALREADY
LIVING OFF OF ARTERIALS. SO I'M
I'M KIND OF UNSURE HOW THIS
WOULD HELP THOSE COMMUNITIES.
AND IF WE HAD MORE WAREHOUSING
ON ARTERIALS, WOULD THAT MEAN
THAT HOMES AND SCHOOLS AND PARKS
ON ARTERIALS WOULD NOW BE TRUCK?
WOULD WOULD HAVE MORE TRUCK
CONGESTION? I, I OKAY, ANYWAYS,
THIRD POINT, WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE HOUSING
REPLACEMENT. THE HOUSING
REPLACEMENT IS THE GOOD PART. DO
I THINK IT'S AN REPLACE FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE? ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I THINK IT CAN BE A STANDALONE
THING AND I'D LOVE TO WORK ON
THAT NEXT YEAR, BECAUSE THAT IS
THAT IS TRUE, PEOPLE. THERE IS A
PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL TRAUMA
HAPPENING FROM THE DISPLACEMENT
FROM WAREHOUSES IN OUR REGION.
AND THEN LASTLY IS THE BUFFER,
THE BUFFER COMES OUT OF THIN AIR
LIKE THERE IS NO LOGIC BEHIND
300FT AND 500FT. CARB SAYS AT
MINIMUM 1000FT. AND TO BE
HONEST, OUR ORGANIZATIONS, BASED
ON BOTH THE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE
THAT WE HAVE AND THEN ALSO THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE WE THINK
THOSE BUFFERS HAVE TO BE HUGE.
AND TO BE HONEST, THIS ISN'T AN
ISSUE OF NUMBERS ANYMORE. THIS
IS AN ISSUE OF HOW WE'RE DOING
LAND USE STEPPING BACK AND
ACTUALLY MAKING SURE INDUSTRIAL
SITES ARE STAYING IN INDUSTRIAL
PLACES AND RESIDENTS ARE STAYING
IN RESIDENT PLACES. AND OUR
BUFFERS LOOK DIFFERENT. THEY'RE
JUST NOT A COUPLE FEET AWAY
BECAUSE IN THE LETTER THAT OVER
30 ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS SENT, WE SHOWED
YOU, WE SHOW VARIOUS WE SHOW
MULTIPLE EXAMPLES OF HOW THE
WAREHOUSES THAT WERE SO HIGHLY
CONTESTED IN THE REGION WOULD BE
OKAY. AND I ALSO KNOW THE
REGIONS WE WORK WITH. IT'S
PRETTY IRONIC TO BE IN
OPPOSITION WITH FOLKS THAT ARE
THE ONES THAT KEEP THE FLOOR SO
LOW, BUT I KNOW THAT IS GOING TO
BE A CEILING, SO I'M NOT I'M NOT
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT. AND SO
THERE THERE ARE WAREHOUSES.
SURE, YOU SAID IT'S GOING TO BE
A CEILING. I WOULD I WOULD THINK
IT WOULD BE LOOKED AT AS A
CEILING, NOT A FLOOR. I WOULD
THINK THAT WAREHOUSES RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE AT 500FT AT BEST WOULD
BE LIKE, OKAY, WE'RE FOLLOWING
THE LAW NOW AND THAT'S NOT
PROTECTIVE ENOUGH. WE NEED TO BE
TAKING A STEP BACK AND LOOKING
AT HOW WAREHOUSING IS NOT,
ENCROACHING INTO COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S A LARGER LAND USE
ISSUE. YEAH, I'M SURE THERE'S
MORE PARTS OF THIS, BUT IT WAS
JUST SO LAST MINUTE THAT I, I
YEAH, AND WE WEREN'T INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS. SO I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY MORE DETAILS I CAN GIVE,
BUT I THINK SOME PIECES ARE
GOOD. I JUST THINK IT'S THE
OTHER PARTS NEED A LOT OF WORK.
AND IF WE WERE THERE, WE COULD
WE COULD PROVIDE THAT, DO YOU
HAVE ANY REASON TO THINK THAT
IMPROVEMENTS COULDN'T BE MADE ON
THIS? BECAUSE WE GO THROUGH THIS
A LOT AND MY COLLEAGUES HERE.
RIGHT. EVERY TIME WE'RE PUSHING
FOR ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
BELIEVE IN, I KNOW. AND THANK
YOU. AND EVERYONE HERE WHO IS
ACTIVE ON THE ISSUE OF HEALTHIER
COMMUNITY AND I COMMEND YOU FOR
THAT. I DON'T THINK WE WOULD
HAVE EVEN THIS PROPOSAL FOR LAW
WEREN'T FOR THE ACTIVISM OF THE
COMMUNITY AND ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE HERE. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE. SO THE, THE, YOU
KNOW, SOME SOME OF US SEE IT AS
A POTENTIAL HERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD, BUT
STILL NOT HAVE EVERYTHING THAT
WE BELIEVE AND WILL CONTINUE
FIGHTING FOR. WHY ARE YOU NOT
CONVINCED THAT THIS IS THIS IS A
GOOD STEP FORWARD WITH ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT WERE LISTED. ONE
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER REYES IN
PARTICULAR IN THAT AREA, BECAUSE
SHE REPRESENTS THAT AREA, HAS,
INVESTED MANY, MANY YEARS WITH
YOU, I REMEMBER WHEN THIS ISSUE
HAS COME UP BEFORE IN THE
COMMITTEE AND, DIDN'T NGUYEN
DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING, TO MOVE
FORWARD. SO I THINK I THINK YOU
WERE FINE. GO AHEAD, TRY AGAIN.
NO HELLO? OKAY. THERE WE GO. I
THINK IT WAS TO MY FIRST POINT,
I AM UNSURE, I DON'T THINK THAT
THIS THE BENEFITS OF THIS IS
BETTER THAN WHAT WE HAVE NOW. SO
I DON'T I YEAH, I MEAN I JUST, I
JUST STATED THAT WE HAVE A
REGULATION THAT ADDRESSES
WAREHOUSES THAT START AT
100,000FT². AND I AND THAT
BUFFER IS WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH RIGHT NOW. SO WE DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS NECESSARILY
AN IMPROVEMENT. AND I RESPECT
AND APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES WORK TO GET US HERE. BUT
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
THIS ISN'T IT. RIGHT. WELL, I
WOULD HOPE IT'S NOT DONE, YOU
MENTIONED THE SOUTH COAST, MAYBE
WE CAN HAVE THEM COME UP FOR
SPEAK FOR A MINUTE OR TWO. SINCE
OUR. I DON'T WANT TO GIVE MORE
TIME THAN WHAT OUR KEY WITNESSES
DID. BUT IF YOU WANT TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS. YEAH. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ROSS, ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH COAST AQMD,
SOUTH COAST HAS A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS AROUND THE MODELING AND
MONITORING STUDY PROPOSED THAT
WOULD REQUIRE EXTENSIVE WORK AND
POTENTIALLY DIVERT, LIMITED
AGENCY RESOURCES. WE'VE NOT HAD
TIME TO SCOPE THIS FULLY OUT,
BUT WOULD LIKELY COST SEVERAL
MILLION DOLLARS AND TAKES
SEVERAL YEARS. WE'VE ALSO
CONDUCTED EXTENSIVE MOBILE
MONITORING ALREADY AS PART OF
THE AB 617 EFFORTS, AND ALSO
CONDUCTED COMPREHENSIVE
MONITORING AND MODELING ANALYSIS
AS PART OF THE MATES STUDY, WE
THINK THE STUDY IS POTENTIALLY
DUPLICATIVE, THE PRESCRIPTIVE
APPROACH DICTATING HOW WE SHOULD
CONDUCT OUTREACH OR PENALTIES
FOR SINGLE RULES, ALSO
PROBLEMATIC, I WILL JUST SAY
WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH AUTHORS
ABOUT THESE ISSUES OVER THE
YEARS, AND WE APPRECIATE THEIR
WORK ON THIS ISSUE, BUT, YOU
KNOW, WE ARE REACTING TO
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PUT IN PRINT
THIS WEEK. SO WE'RE STILL WE'LL
WE'RE STILL, CONDUCTING ANALYSIS
OF THAT, THANK GOD. OKAY. CAN I
ASK YOU ONE MORE QUESTION? I'M
NOT SURE OF ALL THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THIS, BUT DO YOU HAVE AN
INDIRECT SOURCE RULE? YES.
SORRY. YES. IF YOU COULD COMMENT
ON THAT INDIRECT SOURCE
WAREHOUSE RULE THAT WE HAVE PUT
IN PLACE AND WORK WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS OVER MANY YEARS ON
THAT ISSUE? YES OKAY. YES I NEED
THE GUY THAT WORKS. IF THERE'S
TWO SPECIFIC. YEAH REALLY? I'M
NOT DEFENDING. NO, NO, FOR SURE,
FOR SURE. YEAH THERE, I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR EITHER, EITHER OF
THE TWO AUTHORS, CO AUTHORS.
WHERE DO YOU SEE, OR WHAT'S, HOW
DO WE HANDLE THE ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE ON A NUMBER OF, OF
THESE ISSUES WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE IT, AS FAR
AS, THE DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS
PLACE THROUGH THIS BILL, THEY
WILL HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS. AND IF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WILL HAVE MORE
RESTRICTIVE MECHANISMS, THEY ARE
ALWAYS WELCOME TO USE THAT, AS
FOR WHAT OTHER ENFORCEMENTS, THE
AIR QUALITY, THERE'S GOING TO BE
A REPORT IN 2028, I BELIEVE
SOMETHING THAT WE TALKED ABOUT,
BOTH AUTHORS, SOMETHING THAT MR.
REYES WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAD A REPORT TO SEE HOW THE
INDUSTRY KEEPS IMPROVING. AS
MENTIONED BY ONE OF THE
SENATORS, YOU KNOW, WITH,
INDUSTRY IMPROVEMENTS IN
TECHNOLOGY, THE PARTICULATES,
OTHER ALTERNATIVE FUELS, THOSE
WILL IMPROVE OVER TIME, WE DON'T
HAVE THAT AS OF YET. WE ARE NOT
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING THAT. BUT
THROUGH THE STUDY THAT, MISS
REYES REQUESTED TO BE PUT ON THE
BILL TO SEE HOW THINGS ARE
IMPROVING, THAT'S A WAY TO
ENFORCE WHAT'S BEEN PUT ON ON
THE BILL, I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY OTHER SPECIFIC
ENFORCEMENTS THAT YOU ARE
ASKING, OR MAYBE MR. REYES CAN
DO THAT TOO. AS I MAY HAVE.
YEAH. YES. GO AHEAD, MR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ON ON THE
INDIRECT SOURCE RULE
SPECIFICALLY, I THINK WE NEED TO
BE CLEAR THAT THAT IS MONITORING
THE TRUCKS. THE BILL THAT WE
HAVE TODAY HAS TO DO WITH LAND
USE. AND IF THERE IS ANY
CONFLICT, THERE WAS LOTS OF
INVOLVEMENT FOR THAT INDIRECT
SOURCE RULE. THAT WAS THAT WE
THAT WAS RECEIVED BY FROM CARB.
AND IF THERE IS ANY CONFLICT, WE
NEED TO RESOLVE THAT IN IN CLEAN
UP LEGISLATION, BECAUSE THAT WAS
LONG AND HARD FOUGHT, THAT IS
IMPORTANT. I WOULD ALSO SAY, AND
THAT AQMD SAID THAT THEY'VE DONE
A LOT OF STUDIES WITH AB. 617
AND THAT THAT SOME OF THAT THAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE DUPLICATIVE.
SOMETHING ELSE THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER FOR THE FUTURE IS TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO HAVE TO DUPLICATE THEIR
EFFORTS. WE JUST NEED A STUDY.
SO IF THEY HAVE PRELIMINARY
STUDY RESULTS FROM AB 617 AND IT
INCLUDED TWO OF OUR COMMUNITIES,
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE, THERE MAY
BE OTHERS, BUT TWO THAT I AM
THAT I AM INTIMATELY INVOLVED
AND AWARE OF. WE DON'T WANT IT
TO BE DUPLICATIVE. WE WANT A
REPORT. SO THAT EVERY ANY
DECISION ON THE SETBACKS CAN BE
AN INFORMED DECISION. WE ARE
TOLD THAT WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS
TOO OLD. THE STUDIES ARE TOO
OLD. WE NEED SOMETHING THAT IS
MORE RECENT. AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT ANSWERED THE QUESTION
BECAUSE I MAY HAVE MISSED PART
OF IT. YEAH, OKAY. OKAY. I THINK
WE'RE ANY, IF THERE AREN'T ANY
MORE QUESTIONS, I'LL JUST MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS. I, I AGAIN, I SAID
THIS A FEW MINUTES AGO. HAVE AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF RESPECT AND
FOR THE ACTIVISM, INCLUDING THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
VERY ACTIVE, HAVING BEEN IN A
HEARING BEFORE AND KNOWING THAT
WHAT IT MEANS TO, COMPLETELY
WALK OUT THE DOOR AND NOT HAVE
ANYTHING IN OUR HANDS TO BE ABLE
TO SHOW THE NEXT STEP THAT WE'RE
TAKING, I THINK YOU ALL SHOULD
TAKE CREDIT FOR THE PROGRESS
THAT'S BEEN MADE IN THIS BILL,
EVEN THOUGH IT DOES NOT COVER
EVERYTHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
IN THAT COMMUNITY. I MUST SAY,
FOR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, I
THINK TO SAY NOT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS, TAKING AWAY THEIR
POWERS. LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS HAD
THE POWER AND IN SOME CASES
BECAUSE OF THE COMMUNITY, HAS
IMPLEMENTED STRICTER AND BETTER
PROTECTIONS FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
BUT OVERALL, THIS HAS BEEN IN
THE HANDS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS FAILED. AND
SO TO TRY TO SAY, LET'S KEEP IT
AND RESTRICT IT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, I THINK IS NOT THE
WAY WE WANT TO GO. WE CERTAINLY
WANT LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
BETTER THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING AT
THE STATE LEVEL, BUT CERTAINLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITHOUT THE
PUSH OF THE COMMUNITY HAS NOT
TAKEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH SERIOUS
THE WAY THAT IT THAT IT SHOULD,
I SEE, OBVIOUSLY THINGS THAT
WILL CHANGE THE STATUS QUO, BUT
MUCH, MUCH MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD BE AN ALLY
FOR THAT FOR ALL THESE REASONS
AND OTHER TESTIMONY, I WOULD BE
SUPPORTING AND URGE AND I VOTE,
CAN WE, TAKE THE VOTE, RECOGNIZE
THIS MOTION, SENATOR? OH, YES.
RECOGNIZE, SENATOR WIENER'S
MOTION. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR DURAZZO,
I DURAZZO I CIERTO CIERTO. NO
DOLLY. DOLLY. NO. GLASER SKINNER.
SKINNER I WAHAB. WAHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 42. MOTION MEASURES OUT.
YES, THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.
WAIT A MINUTE. HERE WE GO, OKAY.
THE BILL IS OUT. WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED. MADAM,
I'M GOING.